hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
freddy's in this episode we're gonna
finish this
and what i'm gonna do that i didn't
think of before is that i'm gonna go
take care of monty first
[Music]
yeah i'm a superstar i'm a superstar i
get it because if i take care of monty
first then he can't come and kill me and
then freddy doesn't have to not rescue
me and then he won't feel bad about
letting me down
well he probably doesn't feel that bad
about well he probably says
about letting me down because he's been
doing it so much so he's used to it
and i'm not that disappointed either for
the same reason but i'm gonna go to the
golf course which is probably where i
should have gone in the first place
because
if i remember correctly
there
there really wasn't anything to do with
the phaser blast area that needed me to
take care of one of the animatronics
however i guess i did see vanni there i
guess i wouldn't have had that option
unless there's like a counterpoint
option in
the golf course
but i don't know
so we're gonna go up to the golf course
take the party pass through because
that's why he gave me the party pass
because they didn't have one enough to
go through there
unless there's like some other area with
a party pass that needs that like the
bowling alley needed the dance pass but
whatever i'm gonna go to the golf course
because i'm assuming that's monty's area
it's i think it even said monty's golf
course
[Music]
so that means that there's got to be
something in there that can stop him
from being such an a hole
but uh i'm also prepared to fail
horribly and then land on my face a
whole lot and then just be
overall upset with myself at how bad i
am
i might as well grab some of these
things
oh monty pinata it's a sign come on
freddy
good boy oh today you're being a good
boy aren't you are there any other
secrets here that i'm not seeing
hi
thank you
okay there's got to be something here i
know there was that i remember that i
got that
is that no this is a sign
i'm not seeing anything else what is
that
phaser size mazer size maze
maze
god was there some other way that i
could have gone the maze
there there also could be a thing where
depending on your choices in the game
you go to different places and i don't
know how
accurate that is but you know
it's always possible there could be a
lot more to this thing because i saw the
fazbear theater but i may just have not
made a right choice because there were
like two options for a lot of these i
didn't have to go down to the kitchen
first but i did maybe i picked the paths
that were just gonna give me the most
trouble but
whatever at least it seems like
i'm doing something right hey where are
you going
that's what i thought
oh hey
oh that's that that's fine
okay it's gonna be really unfortunate if
i die
hey monty's golf course i think i
already grabbed all the stuff on this
floor i mean i probably missed something
hey freddy how you doing buddy
yeah i probably missed something
let me just get a quick scan around
oh i did miss something did i miss
anything else i did miss i missed many
things i missed all of the things
all right well that's
that makes me feel bad about my own
gaming ability but whatever oh there's
no way i could have found this
no way now
frozen monty treat sounds delicious
lost in the jungle
okay there was something else over here
kind of on ground floor area
and also how do i get a level 10 pass
how does that happen
maybe up there behind the pier thing
behind chica mermaid no
not so
not such
maybe up the slide can i go up the slide
yeah i thought i saw it over here
didn't i
ready
oh
oh oh oh oh god oh god freddy
freddy
oh god no
ready
freddy
oh god
oh god freddy's gone golden freddy mode
what in the hell
i know he's trapped under the floor but
he's really trying to get out
uh try again pal
there he is
good effort buddy
good effort pal
oh god he's still moving he's still
moving okay all right calm oh i can go
in there and then the other one's in
that boat area okay i didn't know that i
could open that
interesting
oh
that's golden that is definitely golden
[Music]
and
numero tree
hello
somewhere back here
aha oh
didn't even know you could get in here
i can't get in i i'm trying desperately
to get in here there we go
huh
moon plush
well so long as there's not a golden
version of that i think we're all good
whatever though okay so that was all
three out here let's get the party pass
let's go inside let's not die to monty
and let's have a good time playing golf
i like mini golf i do as much as i said
that it was for nerds in all reality i
am the nerd because i like mini golf and
i would rather go mini golfing than
laser blasting anytime
there you go
thanks bell
thanks buddy thank you thank you welcome
to monty's gate
home to hurricane hold on
we're currently closed for the night
come back
wow
[Music]
since there is no flash photography
allowed in monty golf fast cams are
often confiscated here mainly because
they are only sold in monty golf it is a
very clever marketing plan
very clever man very very clever much in
the same way as dj music man was a very
happy nice guy
what does that sound i'm here
please tell me that's just like
normal at
normal ass little robot alligators
oh it is
okay
they still got security patrol in here
why
whatever
uh monty gator golf
fred are you here
oh
ready you round there you are buddy
okay
let me hop in
because i need to see what's going on
here
ah this is cool
i kind of like it
and nothing over there
only got two bars of power left so i
need to be very careful about this okay
what's the map say
oh if i get caught i'm dead
i'm hoping that there's a charging
station it says there's a charging
station
right here
what
am i crazy
where
what are you talking about
huh
this is what
probably one below probably right below
this
maybe
can i jump down there is that a good
idea definitely not not a good idea i'm
gonna do it anyway here we go
ah it was a good idea freddy
ready
[Applause]
i'm here buddy
ready
here he comes hi buddy
all right let's hop in this charger
no no no are you kidding are you kidding
no i'm not going to be able to charge
with freddy this whole time is that what
you're saying to me
is that what you're saying because
that's kind of bs
that's a little ridiculous whoa
oh
uh
well that's a little weird i sure wish
this showed something relevant to my
situation but it do not
uh
shush
oh god
okay
all right oh god no
oh hi hal
um
okay
is that him
i don't know what's going he's supposed
to be patrolling here okay there he goes
all right
okay
oh sorry roxy turns out you suck at this
game
maybe back here
oh
uh-huh yeah i'm gonna do that
oh god this is a bad idea why am i doing
this why am i doing this why am i doing
this why am i doing this
it's a flashlight upgrade that's not bad
okay
all right okay
i don't see anyone patrolling here
ugh it's awfully nerve-racking
okay
can i have it i don't know if that does
anything for me level seven
there really aren't level seven things
i'm just gonna hide in here
okay what's happening okay it seems fine
might have been for something like
before the end of the game which i'm at
that's good
that's gonna be helpful
what's this
it looks like an old camera
oh
oh interesting
if you are in trouble use the camera
keep in mind that it will not work on
monty due to his sunglasses yeah i
figured that out for myself it's awfully
inferior to the uh
phaser blaster
that i have
could be hot wait whoa whoa
behind the maze i still can't find what
is making all the clanging noise in the
ac system this is the fifth visit this
week if i could reach that stupid vent
behind the exercise maze room i could
get to the catwalks over gator golf and
take a look maybe someone who works in
mazercy's knows how
all right well that's good um i still
haven't figured out how to stop monty
that's a thing that i need to figure out
um
whoa whoa
no thank you not that door
not that door thank you
whoa
matrix much
oh god
hi
okay
all right so we got the camera but
that's not in any way helpful because
i'm willing to bet that the
uh
laser blaster is superior and neither
work on monty
so good great
what did we get no flash no flash
photography items will be complicated
and kept in monty golf security office
okay
you're there whoa there's two of them
whoa oh my no no no not like this not
like this hide hide hide
hide i'm not i'm not playing around here
i'm not playing around i'm not playing
around i don't know why i can't charge
anything and i'm not
100 sure what is the deal with
like
oh it's part of that one okay
investigate the vent in mazer size okay
so i gotta get out of here and i gotta
go to mazer size
oh god no no no no no
i like that not like that not like that
okay there's got to be way
um back up that doesn't involve running
into those security patrols directly
which i have been doing
and that's what i want to avoid first
time in this whole game that i'm
actually trying to avoid these bastards
properly because the stakes are just a
little too high
okay okay okay okay
okay okay this is good man i wish i
could play some golf
boy howdy i would love to play some golf
okay whoa
this is super cool
um
this certainly looks elaborate and
lovely why did i have to jump down oh
there's stairs right there okay stairs
right there okay perfect no no no no no
[Music]
okay okay okay
don't eat me
oh my god
hi freddie you still there huh
all right good job keeping an eye on
that non-functioning
thing
we gotta go to mazer size come on freddy
come on boy
come on
there you go
get over here you're in you're close
enough you're in right
you're in
good you're in okay all right that's
great
[Music]
all right good let's go uh mazer size it
up i hope i don't die
kind of just a common theme in my
adventures
death would be inconvenient
there must be like three more security
badges out there somewhere which would
let me get to level 10
and i'm guessing it's just in the
different areas there must be like a
security office in each of these
uh
zones
wasn't there a stair ah over there in
each of these zones there must be like
another security office and if i just
find 10 of them i'd have enough badge to
be able to
open the 10 doors
not that i know that it would be that
helpful for me but
oh are you coming this way you're coming
oh my god no no no no
where'd you go
okay
perfect
i just i don't want to play right now i
don't want to play i don't want to play
i mean i'm playing the game but i don't
want to play around right now
no time for fun and games i'm
super starcade that's different
[Music]
oh my god
i've never been more scared of those
things
never
prizes
prizes i haven't been there
okay what are you doing what do you know
good
l chips i've never been in l chips
either
god i
i'll i will expl what are you doing what
are you doing
what are you doing and why are you i'm
going
oh no no no
no
hide hide hiding hiding immediately
that's not a heidi are you kidding me
oh my god no
oh she doesn't have eyes oh my god
please i'm just gonna hide i'm gonna
hide
gonna hide
please don't come over here where am i
where am i where am i there's some
cameras here there's no cameras here
it's on the wrong floor it's in gator
golf why are you down there
that's not where i am there we go
okay we're fine we're fine we're fine
we're fine we're fine we're fine we're
fine we're fine
hey i got a pass
for the maze
i love mazes
love mazes chica's delicious bath to
fitness
without oh my god
i hate those things so
much work off the calories while you eat
sign up for a membership pass today
super cool perks include discounts on
pizza nachos fries and cookies
now that's the smell of fitness
uh-huh
real fit there pal
good job
this is delightful though i love the
aesthetics
i do love the aesthetics
the
intention and meaning behind the
aesthetics i'm not a big fan of but you
know the aesthetics
really great
[Music]
hi
oh
no you don't
that's right carry on carry on carry on
they always do that these buttons change
the maze
i wonder what the right combination is
i also wonder what the right combination
is
how would i know that
secret message
where's everyone leo was the only one
who had a copy of the maze control key
but i haven't seen him for months maybe
that creepy bot knows where the key is
leo was supposed to train it to work the
maze instead he tricked the bot into
doing busy work under the daycare
theater
i'll check after all the staff meeting
tonight what
i gotta go under the daycare theater
so that did send me to the theater down
there
okay
so
there is a vent in this maze that leads
to the monty golf catwalks i believe
there is a control panel for the maze
around here somewhere
around here somewhere where is here i
mean i i know where it was i was just
there so i'm guessing that the maze in
its current configuration will not allow
me to get to the place where i need to
go for the maze or the the vent right
that's what i'm gonna glean from this
information
and i need to go get a key from some
creepy bot
that's under the daycare theater
right that's what you're saying to me
right now that's what you're saying
i'm guessing
yes
yes absolutely okay
so i need to go
apparently get a key i doubt my mission
is gonna say that specifically
uh
yep
so i gotta go get a key from where are
you where you are yeah i'm gonna wait
i'm just going to try to test the
buttons but
yeah i can't do anything
yeah i can't do anything until i have
that key so i gotta go get the key
uh which is under the daycare theater
i think
he's coming he's coming
no
every time he always weaves just the way
i don't want him to weave i'm going to
nail chips i'm going in
oh
hi el chip
i bet i'm your favorite why are you here
what it what i don't hear any stomping
i just hear
okay
you're not gonna bother me are you
no
you wouldn't
you wouldn't dream of it
okay
i'm guessing this isn't much but just
like a bonus
probably some kind of an item here
although i haven't seen it oh there it
is
okay fizzy fazz monty that's good it's
got an up arrow which is like the same
as the uh
oh no no no no no none of that none of
that none of that none of that oh god
nope where am i where am i what is this
what is this where am i what is this
what is this and where am i freddy bro i
can't summon freddy here what is this
where am i
where am i you tell me right now where
am i
whoa oh no please not like this
why would you do this oh that's a
security button oh that's a oh
no where am i
it's the superstar kade i think i saw a
sign say
okay
oh it doesn't seem like anybody is
coming after me
so that's good
okay
i'm sure that there were items in here
but i just didn't have the time to go
looking for him and freddie's not coming
so you know how it is i just gotta make
do with the best i got with what i have
ah also it's really bright i opened up
this window here and it's too bright
hold on i should pause before i do
anything stupid like that also it's like
exceptionally hot
it's like roastingly hot in here
ah there's a vent back there
what does that vent lead to
don't
what does this vent lead to
oh god no i hear that no i yeah i heard
that yep okay don't i'm just gonna run
i'm just gonna run i'm running
i'm running
i'm running away
i'm running why am i running where am i
running to i don't know
but i'm running
oh
okay
glitchy maze great
good
okay
where does this lead
oh i see i see i see okay but this is a
security office which means that there's
probably
a badge here which would give me the
level
eight
[Music]
i don't know what happened all i did was
take the badge do not panic that office
oh god no oh what what
oh
my god
i feel
nothing
i feel an emptiness inside of me
i feel an
open sore oozing pus inside of me
oh
my god okay i guess i get to do all that
over again
i'll be back
okay i have
gone to mazer size and i have gotten the
thing that's like you need the message
that's like you need
leo train and trick the bottom do busy
work under the daycare theater
okay so i know where the daycare theater
is because i saw it before but i gotta
go to the daycare to get there so i'm
gonna do that
and i know what the weight of the
daycare because i know this place like
the back of my hand now
okay
so now that i got that underway go to
the daycare find this creepy bot quote
unquote under the daycare i don't know
what that means
but okay
i still don't know why freddie can't go
in the charging stations but i'm just
not going to rely on it i'm not going to
worry about the collectibles i'm not
going to worry about any of that i want
to take care of the mystery here first
and that's what's my main priority is
that's what i'm gonna do and i'm not
gonna worry about anything else because
if i worry about anything else i'm just
gonna end up dead and then i gotta do
this all over again but they won't stop
me because i'm unstoppable and i can't
be stopped and nobody would ever
try
so that's what i'm gonna do
that's what i'm gonna do
oh
i can get in them now
or maybe it was just that one that was
broken i don't know either way
good to know that's there
but i'm good i'm set
i'm
in it to win it
and winning it is going to the theater
and going under you know what actually
since freddy works never mind
spoke too soon there
spoke real too soon
oh there you are okay thank you
i'm just gonna ride them out because
i don't have time for any of the other
i'm not gonna worry about the
collectibles that's not why i'm here
it's not what i'm doing i'm going to the
theater because i know that it said
something about a creepy bot under the
theater and wherever that is where i'm
gonna go and that's what i'm gonna get
there were nothing ever gonna be a
problem for nobody
excuse me hey officer lovely day we're
having
and francais
hello
what was this about under the theater
what was this thing was this something
was this important
was this something important i don't
know about that
nah just a frozen chica treat okay i
can't get there how do i get there
right
how do i whoa
how do i get through there
i know i was able to get up uh
uppy in the the upper uppy
hello i know i was able to get into the
upper uppy before let me try to go into
the upper uppy let me just see what this
was first
uh no that's not important
so i'm gonna go to the upper uppy
and maybe because this has a stair to go
uppy that goes around those gates maybe
yeah maybe if i go up here and then go
downy the other one that'll get me to
where i need to be
thank you freddie
your thick ass is saving me
is that a button
no no no time no time running out of
power no time there is no time yes
perfect this is what i wanted
perfect yes it's got me around this is
where i needed to be this is where i
needed to go okay i'll pop out here
okay but freddie you stick close by okay
i don't want any excuses
aha this is what i'm looking for the
creepy music has begun which means that
no
no no
freddy you stay nearby
freddie you be right here okay you you
stay
okay
the answer move blue to the corner you
should be able to work it out from there
move blue to the corner i should be able
to work it out with my big brain
anything's possible
okay they seem deactivated for now is
there a map of this area
yeah i wish i could zoom
uh
nope all right i'm on my own
whoa
chica of the sea a part up that was so
blurry i can't even read it something
delight
uh-huh
oh my god
careful now
aren't you cute
oh easy there pals
what you doing down here
freddy
come here there's a
it's a present here and i got a bad
feeling
gonna
stay facing this direction
okay
okay access event okay that's what i'm
gonna do
and i'm willing to bet that nothing has
changed
oh my god everything's changed
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god
freddy uh can you protect me from these
things
i really hope you can
i really hope you can because i need to
i'm gonna we're gonna gun it okay
please tell me that you can protect me
[Music]
low power okay i'm hopping out
whoa
hi fred okay
we're so far so good we're fine
we're never going back down there again
but we're fine
okay
daycare party rooms what does these even
mean
what is any of that this is probably
important for something
balloons yes
happy birthday sing only the approved
freddy fazbear and friends birthday song
no copyright infringing
okay no extra party
keep on schedule okay
sure right
no no no no no no no no where you going
no
that's a slow orbit my dude
okay
sneak
okay we're good we're good we're good
we're totally fine
oh my god
oh my god this is gonna be a nightmare
you guys in your weaving paths
how do i get by you guys the most insane
path i've okay now they're oh no no
they're not
what
how how would i
i don't i don't know i i don't know
freddy's low on power or else i would go
oh this is impossible there's no way
there's just no okay there might be yes
yes no yes no oh my god i'm dead i'm
dead i'm dead i'm dead i'm dead i'm a
dead man i'm a dead man
oh my god i'm dead who's that behind me
oh god oh god no no not now no
oh god i oh my god freddy could you
please rescue me
no oh oh god he did the thing
i don't know how i'm alive
why does it say red
don't be red
where
you can't see me
no i'm not
you don't know that
there's no camera that shows this spot
this one barely
maybe here yeah
yeah help me speed off into the
afterlife i know
god this is a pain in the ass to get
through
okay
i can't remember which one i'm in but
i'm in one of these
okay
you're gonna hop out now
oh my god
why does it still say red why is it
still red oh my god why
oh my god
freddy could you please
freddie
did you actually show up no you did not
that's great okay
it seems like he
has gone away
oh my god
[Music]
oh no he's over there
so monty's still there
okay
i'm actually being strategic about this
i can't believe it but i'm actually
trying at this game
the hell is that
okay but i got what i need unbelievably
i have what i need
i can't believe it but i have what i
need
oh my god if i don't get this
thank you
does he have power now does he actually
have power
i'm a double jack
okay he do he do he do he do
he do
okay
ah
this is too stressful i can't uh my
heart can't take this
that's a rock
uh
so now i go back to mazer size
sun flush wow sure looks like golden sun
plush but whatever
uh
i'm okay
i know you're very worried about me but
go for the mazer size get some exercise
in blue in the corner or something like
that
i'll figure it out from there
we're all good
everything's fine
and then i'm willing to bet that once i
do this get the last upgrade what i'll
need is to have
uh
like i'll need probably need all 10
badges i'll probably have to get them
and that'll be difficult because i'm
probably going to end up making monty
ah harder don't know
okay i may exercise
made it to mazer size still no saves
guys still no saves
that's fine who needs them oh my god i'm
gonna make it yes okay
all right
okay
why i didn't do anything oh
what
what did i do
what what what sorry i'm sorry what
defeat monty what about defeating monty
i haven't
that's not i have chickens
what defeat my i didn't do anything
though this
this took me a long time
like
way too long do i have a map of the maze
here oh well there's the vent okay
i see oh okay okay gotcha okay so the
vent i see three blue here's uh it's in
that corner over there okay i see i see
i see okay there's no path there right
now
right okay
no path no path i hit that twice no path
no path nothing
still nothing how did these go orange
they were blue just a second ago wait a
minute where's the vent
oh the vents over there
in that corner oh
oh
i'm dumb
okay
so it's something about
there are five sections
in this if you look at it like this
the buttons are just to move the whole
thing no no that moved it the other way
yeah yeah yeah no
what just happened okay it's see it's
super weird this is three i think
they're this way these strips are that
way which means that
this one here would actually be five
alright i figured it out
this is moving this grid left and right
the other way would move them all up and
down the numbered order of them changes
depending on what you're doing one two
three four five one two three four five
so according to this here this is
in the in the vertical directions this
is one so one would move left and it
would put blue in that yes
okay
god that's a terrible way to do this but
i got there eventually
all right right up like that left yeah
what okay left one two
three yep yep yep does that is that if i
go that way around this way if this is a
path around this one which i think it is
then that should do it
right i'm not gonna get caught by the
security guard right here i could have
gone apparently
just playing it safe just playing the
safe my god
that
took
oh no you don't
you don't don't
i
i know you're there do not i swear to
god i swear i swear i swear
oh my god
oh my god if it did if it would have
oh wow
i can't belie i say i'm playing it safe
and then just suddenly
i can't go in here anyway
oh my god i just realized like i don't
think i can go well no yes i can
oh my god that
freaking douchebag
that
okay
so i think man that took a while like i
cannot overstate how long that took
oh
damn it
oh damn it it wasn't even right anyway i
thought that oh i thought that was this
gap behind that wall
there
is a path
i'm gonna go for it
if i could run
oh no
you now
oh my god no
where are you
i swear
i was ready to destroy everything i was
ready to destroy
everything
i was so ready
to just
obliterate
everything
i was gonna burn it all down
uh
shut up
okay
ed can i go
what
there okay i had to go in slanty
oh hey
here i am
i kind of forgot that this is what i was
going for anyway
what does that do
why is this here what is any of this
what
can i
oh i can use this
okay
what
oh
oh god no
no
oh no
what i'm gonna do
oh god what am i doing what am i doing
what am i doing
do i gotta wait hold on it said
something about filling us
oh my god no
oh my are you kidding me
oh no
oh my god
i don't
i think i gotta hit something in the
hole in one over there i think
i can't check
whoa
oh god
okay
use it god damn it
oh my god oh my god oh my god i did i
get it
i don't know
it's not a good shot clearly the right
one is there
oh god
where
where oh my god yeah he's defending that
one
no no no no no
whoa
oh where's he going
oh god
no do i hit him
i see i see i see i just got to do with
anything where is he where'd he go
hey
no no no no no no
no no no
no
let go let go let go
let me go let me go
oh god oh my god run
oh my god that's not fair
uh-huh
there's no need
there's no need there is no nide
come on
[Music]
oh god where'd he go
where
oh
god yep oh god
oh god
where
there
oh god this is dead end no it's not
thank goodness
oh my god
no no no
stop
god
[Music]
oh god where oh
i don't like how you do that come on
oh i did it what did i did
splash here
hurricane bucket
press the i don't know what do i do
is it what is it what is it what is it
fill the splash bucket i did
oh god where oh
oh i didn't
that gun was just emptied
[Music]
okay
foreign
huh
this is the most insanely harrowing
adventure i've ever seen
in my life
where do i go from here
where am i going
huh
hello
what
huh
where do i go
what
oh i see
okay
right
okay i'll save my energy for
case music man's coming after me
oh
hello
hi
i'm here now
good to see all of you
boy i wish i could save
i know where i am i've been here before
i think i get out this way
okay
oh my god
oh god i hope i don't mess up the
upgrade in parts and services god i hope
i don't mess up the upgrade in parts and
services
boy i really hope i don't mess that up
oh my god
okay freddie
where you at big guy
why are you up there i don't know
whatever okay fredster
come here boy you here
there you are good boy
time for an upgrade you're gonna be real
sharpie sharp
i'm hoping that this just like is
actually the end and if it's not i have
no idea what i'm gonna do i literally
have no idea what i'm gonna do if this
isn't the end
i i don't know
i've had to play
so
carefully the slightest mistake
and i'm a goner i know that
i know that
but here we are
ah
this is it
all comes down to this just very
carefully
preparing for upgrade procedure
okay we now enter the protective
cylinder all right easy this is easy
this is easy
easy begin by opening the arm casing
okay click on the arm to open the casing
you got it disconnect the collar cables
to remove the old forearm it is
important that you match the pattern
correctly
[Music]
easy
great now place the new armature into
the forearm casing what
oh
with the new armature inserted reconnect
the colored wires
[Music]
great job now close the casing
good job
now use the testing console to run
diagnostics and complete the procedure
okay
easy
[Music]
okay
oh okay that's it
well done there is no need to perform
the procedure on the other arm the auto
assist did it for you oh great thanks
thanks for auto assisting thank you
all right finish
okay
use monty's claws to open special gates
scattered through the pizza plex i have
seen those yes arms are different
where did you get these parts i'd rather
not say
how fortunate
i should now be able to smash through
the cyclone fences around the building
the way monty does exactly like he did
okay
is that it
oh god no
find the prize counter security office
on the third floor why is that there
find that i know where that is
but why is that an objective
i did want to go to the prize counter i
guess
all right
but now i can smash through cyclone
no
not
today
not today
recharge maybe you want a chargey charge
i don't know
i would like to go out this way but
apparently i cannot well it is a long
a.m okay so if if it's about security
offices they're clearly the one
uh
in uh the fazcade that i died from and
then there's
there's uh probably there's one in this
prize counter area so that's another and
then there would just be one more
wherever the last one would be i'm not
sure where
but
there's a prize counter somewhere
[Music]
this is too much it's too much for my
tender disposition there were some gates
down in the utility tunnels but i'm i'm
guessing that just kind of connects me
back
to other places right
yeah probably i'm gonna answer my own
question
okay prize counter
oh i see here's the problem
how do i get in there
okay
yeah there must be a back way in um
level three
yeah it looks like through the fascade
that was that security that might have
been that security office i'm not gonna
say anything confidently because i don't
say anything confidently i don't want to
i'd rather not
so maybe
if i go through here
because this is out of order but i was
able to get there through l chip
so i just go through l chip
where are you
it's done that before it did that before
and it was nothing
okay this is fine
this is fine this is fine this is fine i
know where to go
i know what i'm doing
is that order that's fine hi
nothing here i just get to that security
office what i think went wrong last time
in that security office is i
i i exited it
and i wasn't supposed to do that
i should not have done that okay here it
is
this is it okay
so i just gotta grab it
and then i stay in the office because i
got it's probably gonna make me play
some kind of five nights at freddy's
close the doors thing
this area is off limits to guests
no no no
freddie i don't know what happened all i
did was take the badge do not panic that
office is now on lockdown
i can deactivate the alarm but it will
take some time
okay
okay so i can close these doors right
so i should be looking are you hiding
from me oh my god oh my god nope nope
close close
oh my god close it
maybe
not yet
and let me look i i where am i okay
you're there you're there
okay
i can't keep these doors closed the
whole time i'm losing power
okay
okay no one's by there
no that's a different door what door is
that
oh you're there now you're there
oh god what do i do
no
not like this
i don't know how to play properly
okay there's nothing here i could open
this one
you coming over here
oh god
i really need to open this door
okay
i don't hear anything
nothing here that was a big freaking
waste of energy
i am
still beautiful okay here she comes
i just gotta pay attention which way
she's going right
there's two animatronics there oh god
what is happening to monty
oh god okay you're going right
you're going left
you're going right okay
we're good
here he comes
gonna close this door closing closing oh
my god
oh
no
god
oh
or are you kidding me
oh my god
oh my god i was right there the pizza
place
i
be kind to me
i've been asking
could you go check out my podcast with
bob and wade it's called distractible
there's a link down in the description
below it's a great funny time
with me bob and way just having a laugh
they would do me
a world of good if you could go check it
out
link right in the description
i'm gonna go i will pick this up and
finish it in another episode
but
gotta call it here or else i'm gonna
lose my sanity
so thank you everybody so much for
watching
and as always
i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you